if you go back and revisit some of the
television you watched as a kid you
might be surprised about what networks
used to regularly throw in front of you
some of our most beloved childhood
favorites and cult classics were
actually pretty terrifying in their own
ways
here are some TV shows that gave us
nightmares as kids are you afraid of the
dark probably every kid's favorite scary
show in the 90s are you afraid of the
dark included quite a few nightmare
inducing moments for example the tale of
the pinball wizard which probably kept
some kids away from arcades for a few
years excuse me sir how about the tale
of the dark music which proved that
monsters living in closets are pretty
creepy
especially when they're being polite
[Music]
hello even watching it today there are
some pretty horrific concepts alien
abductors the old lady down the road
being a witch ghost clowns these terrors
and more could all be found on cable TV
and during many sleepless nights the
nightmare room when the lights fade in
the moon rises anything can happen
The WB's version of are you afraid of
the dark the nightmare room also
included a splash of The Twilight Zone
and it was occasionally just as scary as
both based on the book series by RL
Stine some of the episodes were truly
disturbing like dear diary I'm dead for
instance because nothing's better than
reminding children of their own
impending mortality and the fact that
they may die at any moment many of the
episodes dealt with ghosts and haunted
things but aliens and cursed summer
camps also figured in unfortunately the
show proved short-lived only lasting one
season goosebumps
also a product of the kid warping mind
of RL Stein the Goosebumps series of
boats was too scary to read after dark
and the TV show didn't disappoint either
perhaps the creepiest part of the series
was slappy an evil ventriloquist dummy
that was basically a slightly less
murdery version of Chucky slappy was
created out of coffin wood by an ancient
sorcerer and was hell bent on enslaving
children like you do you and I are one
inseperable um ice me puppets are creepy
enough as it is but we can never look at
puppets the same way after slappy had
his way with us hey dummy can't hurt you
he's not even alive he's dead
[Applause]
eerie Indiana another one season show
eerie Indiana was like an x-files for
kids before the horror intact and no
bizarre alien pregnancies many of the
episodes revolved around urban legends
like Bigfoot and other strange beings
with the occasional gruesome death of a
classmate resulting in a haunted heart
transplant because again reminding kids
that life is fragile is probably the
fastest way to ruin the rest of their
lives Doctor Who today the British
science fiction series Doctor Who enjoys
plenty of critical acclaim and
mainstream fandom but when the show
first aired in 1963 it was intended to
be an educational program by the time it
hit its stride in the 70s and 80s it
looked like the taxpayer-funded
production that it was low-budget
limited sets and guys in cheap suits
portraying aliens and monsters still the
show's deadly serious tone combined with
relentless rubber creatures who spoke an
unusual accents hey I take offense to
that made this show fairly creepy for
kids who snuck out of bed to see what
their parents were watching Courage the
Cowardly Dog pit a timid purple dog
against a parade of surreal monsters at
a farmhouse in the middle of nowhere and
you have Courage the Cowardly Dog the
Cartoon Network original series launched
in 1999 and had no shortage of
supernatural malevolence from rooms made
entirely of guts to mind-control
parasites oh and the occasional end of
all life on Earth as well but cares the
only thing better than reminding kids
that they're gonna die is reminding them
that everyone else is gonna die too
yay slim Goodbody this recurring series
of short segments which around drawing
Captain Kangaroo in the 70s was supposed
to teach kids good habits like why is
important to exercise and the vegetables
a healthy birth creator and slim
Goodbody actor John Burstein went about
doing that in a questionable way
wearing a form-fitting flesh-colored
unitard decorated with realistically
rendered pictures of the inner workings
of the human body organs bones veins
blood guts everything unfortunately slim
Goodbody wound up looking like a serial
killer who glues his victims organs to
his body amazingly Burstein still tour
schools with his slim Goodbody character
more amazingly schools let this guy in
the door I'm wonderful and special you
know what else is wonderful and special
keeping your organs on the inside of
your body you freak thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which shows freaked you out as a
kid
[Music]